[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about carbon
products from the air
we have Tito Jankowski joining us on the
show hello hey how's it going thanks so
much for coming on brother great to be
here very pumped very pumped for those
that don't know Tito's background he's
co-founder and CEO of impossible labs
which is creating carbon products pulled
from the air and you can find the links
below to the newsletter as well as by-
calm that's B Y negative calm as well as
impossible labs dot IO and air miners
org and we'll be pulling those up as we
talk Tito let's start things off with
one of our favorite questions to ask our
guests what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world the direction of
our world I I found out this recently
from the presentation on the planet it's
a lot of people think that the planet
can it goes around around the Sun but
actually in in in time it's actually
this like helix yeah I heard that Bucky
fuller presentation so that's that's
what's up with the world continual helix
things are sort of at the same place but
also not mmm and then and then what what
would you say about some of the pressing
challenges that we face as a
civilization and how to overcome them oh
they're great this is where it's at this
is like definitely the time to be boring
I mean the sky is the sky is empty we
just see regular looking stars you know
our planet yeah we've figured out things
like processors and proteins but we're
sort of in between in between those two
things we're here and there's all this
you know ahead of us so we're kind of
writing this right in this first
paragraph of of what we can tell is a
really really long book it is exciting
yeah yeah I love it I love it and then
you mentioned you know processors and
proteins what are ya what are some of
the most important exponential
technologies to help us get through the
next like century let's say next century
gosh I think that climate is a big one
that's what I'm working in I think Trust
is really important the tools that we
have for trust they don't they weren't
designed for the type of trust that we
need now and everything that we're doing
with carbon whether it's monitoring
carbon learning how to learning how to
use it more effectively or pulling out
of the air I think those those are key
technologies that we we are just
beginning to to take a look at it's
really exciting you know I'm super
pumped to unpack that more with you
let's jump into the journey so you're
born in Florida then you move to Hawaii
at four then you stay there till you're
18 then went to brown and then moved to
Silicon Valley that's right so tell us
about this journey who were you as a kid
what got you hooked into science and
technology or got me hooked into science
and technology was my parents our oil
painters and so growing up in Hawaii
they dragged me out to go painting with
them they're going sit in a it's in the
cow field you know cow hanging out or
whatever they're paying a landscape and
I would just think about just more more
mathematical things or more you know how
to have these things all start to fit
together what makes a cow a cow why is
you know why is the grass blowing and
just yet caught my call my interest and
kind of grew into an interest in science
and technology biotechnology really was
was an exciting discovery just
everything is made of DNA right that
that grass that cow us is all there's
this code that's running all of us and
then that that grew into an interest in
in the planet as an entire kind of
biological cell how does that work what
what's the beauty in it what what can be
improved in it yeah and that brought me
to you today yes yes okay so so let's
let's stay on that biotech up a little
bit longer so then it was you know when
you're when you're both in college and
moving out here and you're really
figuring out biotech is something that's
so profoundly important what is it about
biotech that is like a really whole
wakening thing for you
what's awakening for that it's very
similar to my to my interesting climate
is this feeling of a looking at a
rosetta stone and saying there is
language here there is knowledge here we
don't have it yet but but that to
Ulysses there is a point we will and so
sometime between now and then there's
gonna be this beautiful ability to read
ability to understand ability to write
our own story whether that's DNA with
biology or carbon with the climate yeah
yeah okay so so it's like we are gaining
more authorship oh yeah right right
still authorship cool yeah okay like
okay I like that a lot to move back just
so yeah do it
okay perfect awesome all right and then
let's hit on the mission of impossible
labs it's been three years now the
co-founder and CEO and you're pulling
co2 out of the atmosphere it's the
greatest the greatest opportunity
civilization I've ever seen climate you
say that that's what it is
and people need to be handling these
these tangible things that we're gonna
be talking about here in a little bit so
why don't you tell us a bit about what
you guys are doing with impossible labs
yeah terrific I mean that the overall
there are a trillion tons of excess
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere it's
free nobody knows what to do with it
nobody even really wants it if we can
figure out how to pull it out and to
make use of it we can change how the
planet works change our understanding of
what of we've you know we understand
water we understand that these
macromolecules but gases are still
something that we struggled to deal with
and so it's kind of this final frontier
of exploring what is what are the
mechanics that make this planet and this
is a trillion you said tons of of excess
co2 sequestered and is that is that's
excess so that's a that's passed what it
where it was yeah okay right okay it's
four hundred and fifteen parts per
million than today yeah Wow and it was
closer to like 300 episode and fast okay
so you guys are exploring new business
opportunities and climate change with
this greatest opportunity that we have
and one of the things that you guys are
doing is you're making these tangible
physical products okay so yeah so walk
us through these yeah that's right so so
this is made of carbon dioxide that was
in the atmosphere that was pulled out
the little white dots are little beads
of calcium carbonate and the carbon
dioxide that's in that was pulled out of
a direct air capture machine up in
Canada run by carbon engineering which
is a company that's working to build
these machines that can take molecules
of carbon dioxide out of the atmosphere
so a lot of times we hear about putting
carbon into the atmosphere we do it we
certainly put a lot of carbon into the
atmosphere but our ability to actually
pull it out is it's just as really it's
an emerging it's an emerging discovery
of it how do you actually go the other
way and start to start to pull carbon
and use carbon okay and then the so
these this this right here this like
container for this plant these
containers to the plants you sold out
within one hour of these because people
like the idea of like a tangible
physical asset that they can have in
their home that says that hey I'm like
I'm partaking in the process of
awakening with sequestering carbon from
the atmosphere that's right and it's
something that I you know as a team we
were we were always when you start
impossible up searching for that how do
we how do we plug in to climate change
how do we grab on to it how do we just
poke at it and this is this is I think
what people are seeing is this is an
hour
community to to grab onto something
that's just it's been it's been on the
news it's been on TV but it's never been
somebody just kind of hold and say what
do you think about this it's always been
that somebody else is thinking about
working on it now we can now I can yeah
you can it's been like a PowerPoint or
like a new story yeah right
you gave this example to me before the
show you were like there's like
civilization like a billion of us are
like at the door trying to get in but no
one's making a handle that's right more
and so these products are kind of like a
step towards the handle for the door to
get through the climate challenge yeah
exactly it often working on the change
in climate it feels like am i doing
enough am i solving the whole thing at
once and I see a lot of people get stuck
right there and what we wanted to do is
to unlock that and to say look here's
here's a place where you can grab on to
it and start to move so to move the
whole thing I think we need more of
those places that individual people can
can grab on to there's certainly you
know a role for collective action but I
think individuals
single people doing a thing really is
where this is where things change you
know and then so batch two of these is
coming up mm-hmm and batch two of these
can be found at by- that's right we have
a weekly newsletter that you can sign up
for or where you talk about our
prototyping or working on a
up-and-coming product that's a bracelet
that you can wear yes okay and that's
this one here okay so the up-and-coming
product is these bracelets that we can
wear okay and then teach us about the
idea behind the bracelets the bracelet
was coming from the plant arif we said
how do we help people how do we give
people a tool fundamental these are
tools to have a conversation to change
how you think so we want to have
something that you you can keep with you
so I'm really into this like carry the
most people don't want to do that so I
said how do we take the same stuff and
and imbue it into a something that you
can use and so this is a prototype but
we're working on using the materials
that start companies are making it that
pull carbon from the air they have a lot
of these raw materials
that people are still trying to figure
out how do we how do we use that things
like cement or plastic I don't buy a lot
of cement I don't buy a lot of just raw
plastic so how do we make those things
again that that individual people can
can grab onto and and use to better
explore and be curious about the climate
and then what what would you say on a I
want to explain this to people will pull
up on air miners now.org explain to us
this is an index of companies and
projects mining carbon from the air
finally there's like an index of
companies that's very exciting and I
want to know like for this and for for
these products mm-hmm explain to us how
the companies are actually doing the
sequestering of the carbon from there
how are they pulling certainly yeah this
is this is where we start our journey
was around curiosity I think that if
you're if you're wondering how to change
the climate and to be a part of that I
did curiosity is the the key so we
started out just learning about these
companies that were talking in some way
about carbon and pulling it and doing
something with it
and we had we had a spreadsheet of all
these all these companies we discovered
hey this is something that probably
hasn't hasn't really been put together
in this way before and so we created air
miners which is the index of companies
and products pulling carbon from the air
so it was it was just this this immense
curiosity to drove us to find these
companies connect them all together and
start to ask well what can we do with
this stuff and that's that's where you
really start to say okay how do we make
make things using the carbon that the
air miners are pulling out of the air
yes and then what is the the method that
the carbon miners are using what like is
there like a method that most of them
are using that is most common
yeah there's kind of two ways to look at
there's biological pulling of carbon and
then there's synthetic or engineered so
biological is easy if you think about
trees they're they're pulling carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere and they're
using it to make their trunks and leaves
so they can keep doing more of that
and then there's engineered which is can
we build a filter or a sponge that grabs
onto carbon dioxide
and then we can either put in a tank or
we can bury it or basically we get this
like 99% pure carbon dioxide nothing too
exciting
so that's that's kind of the overall
view of air miners and what we wanted to
do was we didn't want to curate it so
much because we think for curiosity that
what really matters is kind of stubbing
your toe on stuff and bumping your head
on stuff it's kind of seeing it so we
put up every company that we could find
that was doing any of this stuff and you
can sort them by alphabetical you can
sort by when they were added
but generally don't take a stance on
like is is this company better or more
successful or something they're all
they're all the same and they're all
kind of right for people who are curious
to come along and say wow what's up with
this how does this work biological
engineered making product making carbon
how's it working nice okay so then the
two biological and engineered two big
ones and it it it seems as though there
are plenty of organizations now around
the world that are doing things like a
planting trees or that they're trying to
make it so that all the phytoplankton in
the ocean can be staying healthy and
doing what they're doing apparently
that's the source of like 70% of our
oxygen laughs and on the bottom that's
right yeah
and then on the other hand there's the
engineering so there's like you said
like making a sponge or this u2 and then
turning that into the so when you when
you do compress u2 turns into like a
rock or how do they turn it into like
how do they take co2 through it's like a
filtration and they're just like no
oxygen and nitrogen we're only keeping
the co2 like how does that
scientifically work yeah basically
there's kind of two steps in that one is
capturing carbon so2 separating it out
from all the other stuff that's in the
air so carbon is only I think it's point
oh four percent of normal air okay which
was that's where you get that 400 parts
per million so there's capturing it and
separating it and then there's kind of
what do you do with it afterwards and so
it's wonderful about the looking at
across the breadth of air miners you see
companies that are specializing in the
different different pieces so some of
them are just capturing carbon dioxide
in terms of what do we do with it
they're kind of like ah maybe somebody
else will figure that out and somebody
else is working on how do we make use of
carbon we actually used the molecules
and
transform them into building materials
or plastics or products okay and how
does do we know how it works when they
do this separation of the 0.04% as you -
do we know like how to get the oxygen
nitrogen out of the way and just keep
the suit - yeah a lot of the
technologies right now are chemical
separation so you have a material that
will kind of grab onto carbon dioxide
and then that's a way to separate carbon
dioxide out from everything else that's
in the air so in the end it comes down
to very simple chemistry
so the carbon calcium carbonate beads
that are used in the in the planter
those are actually sponges that are part
of the direct air caption machine so
they get reused over and over and over
again grab a carbon dioxide then get
heated up and release the carbon dioxide
grab a carbon dioxide release it so it's
this it's a cyclical technology okay in
that particular example
okay grabbing it chemically again
releasing it also chemically into what
is only then co2 right okay and then
from there then it it's in a gas form
that's right we're figuring out how to
turn that into a solid mm-hm how do we
do we know how we do turn it into a
solid then again another chemical change
yeah another chemical change me if you
if you think about kind of the basics
its carbon dioxide and oxygen and carbon
dioxide is carbon and oxygen diamonds
are made of carbon we're made of carbon
so it's sort of like there are lots of
examples lying about of things to do
with carbon but it's kind of murky in
the in the middle of it we can see it's
in the air we can see it gets used to as
the building blocks of the planet and
we're kind of figuring out and kind of D
untangling what's in the middle mm-hmm
okay
okay and then the applications then are
some of the companies that are part of
air miners will do just one part of that
process or some will do a lot of the
process and then some will also do like
the actual burying of so the burying is
one aspect of it so we can so we can
bury the the solve the rock
of co2 back into the ground you said it
was an Icelandic company that's right
there's a company called climb works
that is setting up a facility to be able
to take carbon dioxide from the air
separate it out and then inject it
underground where it gets it just merges
and fuses with the rocks underground so
it's back to that trillion tons of
carbon again we can make products out of
some of it but the trillion tons is a
lot a lot of excess carbon in the air
and we're adding we added the most ever
in 2018 so we're just adding more and
more and more carbon so something we
need to use and live with probably to
store okay okay so we can then use some
as o4 fuel is that right we can use some
for fuel and we can store some in the
ground we can wear some this kind of
ideas okay building materials you know
you can imagine graphene cars just I'm
actually kind of walking into a into a
park and your your frisbee is made of
this material and their sidewalk is is
made of carbon that's been pulled from
the air interesting how you can start to
visualize what this what this new world
would look like and every day you have
more and more of these tools that are
that are pulling carbon from the
atmosphere and we start to see instead
of carbon rising every year we start to
see carbon either plateauing or even
start to fall that's the that's the
world where where carbon removal is
successful so we want to get it down
from four fifteen parts per million down
back to three hundred and then after
that then we are back to what is the
most effective sidewalks and frisbees
and this is a graphene was one of the
uses so so it's not that it it's not
that it may be the most effective
building block for more environments but
for now we want it to be a building
block for the sequestration and get back
to that like homeostatic capacity of the
planet where it was at the 300 that's
right yeah so um and this is okay so on
by negative comm that's where people can
go and sign up
for the the carbon products newsletter
and then you can find out more
information about the little little guy
that you see here on the table and the
the prototype which will soon be
something that people can actually buy
and wear as well that represents their
efforts and getting a tangible product
that resembles their desire to sequester
carbon and share that with other people
cool all right and then come give that
little plant with us Tito
that's the one that I carry everywhere
but you're on the mailing list will our
studio definitely wants impossible labs
yeah a vase for a plant because that way
we can also be the bragging we'll keep
it right on the center of our main table
at all and we'll mention it and be like
hey by- calm like going you know go and
check this stuff out great looks like a
happen yeah stuff like that yeah sure
we're looking for sponsors yeah that's
right that's right yes yeah yeah that's
right everyone that's watching yes you
want to carry this season it would be
more than happy to sell those yeah
whatever yeah whatever whatever you guys
know you guys all know yeah including
Tito and all the perspective people to
grow and support the artists and
entrepreneurs in your communities so
important to support simulation all our
links are in the bio yeah Kerry Kerry
Ron's like yeah Kerry the support that's
right we yeah we need to help that's
true so all right let's hit a couple
other thoughts doo doo doo doo doo doo
okay so you were you were teaching me
this I thought oh so since like quite
interesting so once you do the process
of like sequestering something like
carbon turning it into a product the
moment that you start shipping it around
the world it actually takes away from
what you were trying to do which was
make something that was net
negative carbon emission but use the
process of shipping that's right yeah if
you manufacture a product and you put on
the back of a internal combustion engine
truck that immediately starts to put
carbon dioxide back in the atmosphere
and I think it's that's that's the
beauty of of making these products today
is it's it's a fun to be a part of the
process of figuring this stuff out
because right now it doesn't it sort of
comes together and you're like hey
that's that's not exactly right and so
it's really exciting to be able to be a
part of that process and then a certain
thing of new ways well how do you
actually make a carbon negative product
how to make something that overall pulls
carbon from the air a trillion tons of
carbon dioxide isn't gonna fit on
everybody's wrist so that'd be probably
calculate how many pounds how many tons
of that's the weight of a car so I mean
it's it's car weights of this stuff so
burying the carbon dioxide becomes
another option so carrying out how to
create carbon neutralization by taking
carbon from the air and and storing it
underground
starting with you know these facilities
in Iceland what would an ideal process
look like for making a product that
wasn't that carbon negative I think I
mean ideal process you probably think
about this in kind of a 3d printing
world where it's like on-site on-demand
you're minimizing the the transportation
costs it easily energizing you're
avoiding any like excess energy usage
yes they're like cutting out all these
all these middle steps yes
and then for me to get it would need to
be locally manufactured and then the me
to get it would I would need to be local
and take like walk or bike work take
some sort of uh maybe even an electric
transit still has a battery that
everyone hears has to yeah that doesn't
work as well and it needs to be recycled
so yeah this is tough to figure out what
is net negative that's right yeah yeah
and what would be like a design of like
a city that would be negative would it
be your massive green everything and
composting and air from like recycling
water recycling all these styles of
processes were not knowing missions of
internal combustion engines these are
kind of like the things that you would
see in like a future city yeah totally
so so what negative is refers to is
pulling carbon from the atmosphere so if
you're thinking about technologies that
are carbon neutral so you can switch
from a internal combustion engine in a
car to a electric vehicle then your
carbon emissions drop but you're still
not pulling carbon from the atmosphere
for example if you wanted to so instead
if you if you made your buildings if you
had a machine that would pull carbon
from the air and created carbon based
buildings out of that then you can
imagine that not building itself would
be wood being that negative would be
actually pulling carbon from the air
you'd be you'd be pulling carbon from
there to make those blocks for building
up or pulling the carbon from there to
potentially use as fuel for writing the
building that type of stuff yeah I like
Elan musts brick store so they're
they're part of the part of the boring
company they're digging these giant
tunnels underground have these long
tunnels underground and so they're
selling the the bricks of the of the
underground material so you imagine
having like a brick store for carbon
it's really fun to get into because it's
so a few people have have worked on this
and thought about this so if if you're
curious about this topic it's um
that you can go on air mine is you can
learn about and you can just start to
start to contribute to its this very you
know early early industry that's
emerging so you can you know make up
funny ideas like what if there was a
radio show that was everything on set
was made of carbon dioxide pulled from
the air like it's kind of a joke but
then it actually sounds like well that
sounds pretty cool yeah yeah yeah like
maybe it maybe we maybe we should have a
radio show like that yeah yeah so then
this is like the yeah like you said this
is kind of like the earlier more
formative years of air mining in general
yeah and so the idea is the idea space
for what can actually happen in the
field is so untapped into yeah what are
the other like creative thoughts that
you have around like where we could go
with untapped creativity in the air
mining space
sure I certainly always go to like
interplanetary travel and other other
planets so mining carbon from the air is
something that's certainly part of the
future of Mars Mars is I think it's 95
percent carbon dioxide and their
atmosphere or something whatever it is
it means that if we have technologies to
pull carbon from the atmosphere the
tools would be really well used on Mars
similar to if you have technology to
grab power from the Sun Hawaii is a
great place to go and the North Pole is
not a very good place Mars is like a
great place for for carbon capture and
Earth every day is getting better it's
like in the wrong direction
it's 95.3 95.3
thanks for looking that up you know so
then yeah that the process of learning
how to air mine is exactly what we need
for interplanetary yeah processes yeah
it's a way to look at a atmosphere to
look at a planet and just to see it as
something that we can we can connect
with we can work with yeah yeah yeah so
what exactly so then what is the
ecosystem of the planet that how can we
work within the ecosystem of that plan
so like on Mars is we take the skills
that we learn with air mining and co2
here and we bring those skills to Mars
to help us bring a civilization there
right yeah okay and then that's more on
the that was more unlike the you know
really future apps facing stuff what
about the like the the examples that
you're giving us about the companies
that are like where could where could
people find their involvement like how
can you how can people get started with
doing things like air mining like even
today like here on earth how can people
get started with it
with this yeah going to air mine is
learning about seeing what the startup
companies are doing they're all really
great to talk to so we were first
setting up air miners we mailing all the
companies and kind of crossing our
fingers like would anybody write back
lots of people wrote back people are
really engaged and interested in this
field so it's a great it's a great place
to work it's a great place to just to
read about and then to start to
transform that into what might what
might you do what might what role might
you play maybe it's building one of
these machines or being a part of
testing it maybe it's using using the
products to or designing your own
products even and as there's there's all
these opportunities for for a whole
range of different people I like to say
right now there's there's a small number
of people that are actually engaged and
working on the changing climate there's
a lot people thinking about it and kind
of like waking up in the middle of night
frustrated about it
but in terms of like making figure how
to make it your your day job or maybe
your night job I think there's a lot of
opportunity there for for millions of
people to start to start being a part of
it okay cool so going air miners reading
and learning more and then and then
there is there is there would you say
there's a like would you say there's
like a process for for for ones that
want to creatively endeavor in the space
is there like a think tank or a
accelerator or
yeah are there ones like this that are
specifically focused on the field we'd
have a question in regards to that oh
cool audience question asks if he was an
investor what would be the pitch to him
is that moat go tackle him if he was an
investor who if 50 toe was an investor
know if if Kemal wanted to invest oh oh
woah-oh impossible out here okay what
would be the pitch the pitch is that
there's a trillion tons of excess carbon
in the atmosphere everybody thinks it's
a problem and it's actually an
opportunity and we're gonna figure out
how to prove that oh that's great yeah
nice and short I like that yeah Mark
O'Brien says hi - oh cool yeah hey Mark
nice
and then yeah how about the like
accelerators yeah
or think-tank like where we got working
people potentially like yeah are there
any in the space yeah obviously it's
impossible Labs we're doing some of that
kind of think-tank consulting work you
know I'd check out carbon 180 which is a
non-profit just across the bridge cool
they are working on carbon techlabs
which is an accelerator program designed
for companies working in carbon removal
I also check out nori and Ori they are a
block chain carbon removal company that
has a really great podcast and so those
are you know those are places to connect
to get that kind of to get that
acceleration I've seen that lots of new
people come in and they say gosh since I
heard about this I can't stop thinking
about it like it's so kind of
counterintuitive pulling carbon or you
can just kind of seeing it as this this
thing that we might want to grab on to
and I've just seen people really
accelerate very quickly so you know in
six months you you can become an expert
in air miner in a sense
and and then is it I'm following that
trajectory we were mentioning earlier in
the episode is it kind of like we learn
about all of the air mining technologies
captured these 1 trillion tons of co2
bring ourselves back to 300 parts per
million you know really refine these
different ways that we do that take
those technologies to places like Mars
these types of things
put them in the civilizations knowledge
pool and then we just build things that
don't pollute co2 that's kind of like
the future then afterward that's right
so so eventually you've pulled enough
carbon from the air one question that I
get that I know is really funny if
people ask well what if you caused an
ice age and so I think that really
acknowledges like okay so that's that's
somebody who's really thinking about hey
this stuff is gonna work and then if
because we went to if you go to 200 100
like you know return to a very very cold
planet yeah so I think those are those
are fundamentally powerful advances for
one because this is molecular
manipulation it's what you see in
synthetic biology a lot right now in
carbon removal it's done being it's
using a chemistry and physics very
Virata like physics but I think as
synthetic biology comes along you'll be
able to see because that's what that's
what they're doing is they're
manipulating molecules and so we're
gonna get better at manipulating
molecules we're not very good at it
right now we're like we're okay we can
do computer chips which are like a few
nanometers but to really work on
molecules that's the age that we're in
and carbon fits in that proteins fit in
that biology fits in that okay beautiful
beautiful now maybe another wrapping
thought with the field is the the
overall trajectory of our our
civilization what is another way that we
can remove our own like carbon footprint
that we're emitting on a daily basis
like what are the simple ways that we
can do that ourselves yeah my understand
really interested in like lab-grown meat
I think is really promising there
electric vehicles are cool we looked
into buying one for a last car things
like that means it's probably things
that you've heard of out so to kind of
step into things that you might not have
heard of yeah I think that you know
pulling carbon from the atmosphere is
still this really exciting topic but
overall so really to push it I would say
look for opportunities to to work on
this stuff look for opportunities to
maybe it made me mean you read a hundred
books this year but just like step into
it if the climate is something that you
see is like somebody else is telling you
what to do
it just doesn't mmm it's not exciting
and curiosity driven so the more you can
jump into it if you really like food
great like scramble around your diet and
like become vegetarian or vegan if you
like to drive like look intellect your
cars they're pretty freaking awesome
like find a way to find something that
you're excited about or take the thing
that you're already excited about the
thing that you talk about all the time
and people are like wow this person
really likes this and just like google
that topic plus climate or plus carbon
and figure out like how might we think
differently about this because that's
what we really need is we need
jewelers to type in like oh well I'm a
I'm a jewelry jewelry person plus carbon
is like oh well okay what if you made
diamond jewelry I've been sequester
Arbonne sequester diamond jewelry right
you just you can kind of just like take
what you're doing and tag on carbon and
you'll come up with something that
potentially and likely no one has ever
even considered like love it live
broadcast plus carbon like okay like
that what do we come up with yeah cool
cool so another one of the things is to
take different edges of what huh is
known by us and on our knowledge graph
and try and plug these different alloys
into carbon sequestration plus
neuroscience or plus blockchain or plus
energy there's so many options
healthcare you know where could these
things be applied yeah okay cool and
then let's ask a couple questions on the
way I do you feel like we covered
impossible labs well yeah totally know
the stuff we needed to hit yeah the
newsletter I think is we'd love to be
see people in the newsletter mark who
wrote in as one mark and Sarah's that
determined are part of the the
newsletter team so it's just it's like a
you know we every week we talk about
exciting stuff happening and carbon
removal and it's very it's very personal
so it's not just like a you know a real
of what happened it's just more of it
it's story about this adventure so
that's a great way also for people to
get engaged and involved again that's
the newsletters at bitly bi t ly for
slash Tito - carbon so go and find out
there the links in the bio everyone kill
it
so my questions come out I had some more
questions okay yeah ask one of the
questions then we'll dive into that and
show well he wants to know if kid carbon
capture recreate the reef or save it
recreate the reef or save it
question can carbon capture recreate the
reef or save it
reefs I heard there's interesting stuff
going on with taking corals and putting
them in a blender and then kind of
spreading it out or something so I think
there's some some potential there but
you had to do like the reefs plus carbon
sequestration thing reefs might turn out
to be a really great way to pull carbon
dioxide from the air combine it with
calcium in the ocean and to grow reefs
so maybe that becomes a place where
we're comfortable and excited about
pulling carbon from the air
maybe our buildings and our sidewalks
and our and our reefs and it seems as
though when we head down from four
fifteen parts per million down to back
to 300 that's slowly there's a process
of healing that happens with the notion
acidification that's occurring right oh
yeah you know of course that's that's
not something that anybody has ever
thought it was reefs plus carbon
sequestration I've never heard that
before
so exact rate it's like you can come up
with it and you know what's what's your
guess about it will it help her or or
hurt reefs he's also looking to invest
five billion dollars go to PayPal series
we'll hook you up yeah great also what's
Kamal's last name again la mati kamala
mati yeah he owes me five dollars
Oh for that sandwich for that sandwich
[Laughter]
thanks for watching come on
thanks for watching them all mark thanks
for watching everyone we greatly
appreciate it
let's do a couple questions on the way
out Tito what do you think where do you
think we come from before we're born
into the world and what do you think we
go after we die that's a big Zen one
there's that whole Zen Kuan it's like
what's what's your parents
what's your face before your parents
were born or something I mean it's it's
we come from we come from the Stardust
we come from Stephen Hawking's
calculation of what's right what's right
before the is a Big Bang I think we come
from that sort of energy bouncing around
and and intelligent life is right now
just on this one this one spot but it's
obviously there's a lot of spots to
explore and discover and what's the most
controversial belief you hold
it still seems like the idea that
climate is an opportunity is something
that for the people that are really into
the environment explan it's not it
doesn't quite sit very well to say I
think a lot of people are gonna come
along and make a lot of money and
working on this yeah yeah so that's
quite controversial yeah yeah now many
people are thinking about it that way
yeah yeah if you just put yourself in
those shoes the world looks so different
yeah this is an opportunist an
opportunity yeah it's just everything
that is like oh my god we're all dying
world dying even though that's like
exactly a little financial incentive to
save it to save the planet yeah that's
what works for me is I get out of bed in
the morning and I like I think about
things that are they're exciting and fun
and interesting if it's a gloomy day
outside I'll just pull the covers up you
know I mean it's and we need to me I
think the proof has kind of been seeing
where the action is coming from I don't
see a lot of action coming from from
from fear it just it sort of gets it
gets stuck and it becomes about it
becomes about people or interpretations
or relativity rather than exploration
and curiosity and solution does it I
love it and this is exploration
curiosity this is this is that distilled
down into a physical thing that you can
say okay that's right this is where it's
at is that the future is optimistic and
driven by driven by real things that are
being actually developed like these
things aren't just somewhere in the
future and maybe somebody will invent it
this machine up in Squamish British
Columbia that's working to pull carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere
there's machines all over the world and
tools all over the world and drones all
the world that are learning to plant
trees at a hundredth of the cost of
having a person going planting yeah I
mean that's I'm grounded in possible ISM
is this term I came across recently it's
from Hans Rosling who's a sad to
statistician and he really believes in
possible ISM which comes from it's more
than opera it's more than optimism
optimism is like everything's gonna be
great
but possible ISM is grounded in here's
the things that are happening they're
seeing you're watching this show and
you're seeing some guy who walks around
with a plane
it's made of carbon from the air yeah
like okay that's that says a lot about
what's possible yes in the future yes
and so we embrace that that possible ISM
yes yes
so you carrying around the edge of what
we're doing to solve some of the
pressing challenges is yeah is your yeah
constantly reminding people everywhere
you go up that edge and and oh and
increasing people's awareness yeah
that's great
how about do you think we're alone in
the cosmos hmm math tells me that we're
not and but I my eyeballs tell me that
we are because I look out the stars and
I say okay doesn't seem like I see any
life but math tells me that there's a
lot of stars and and it seems like there
should be life somewhere on one of them
they don't on this talk but on the
planet right yeah yeah do you think
we're in a simulation I I think it's
more exciting and interesting to live in
the first the real deal first the end
again it's that that same feeling is
like as a as a human being emotionally I
want to be this like one of the first to
explore this explore this game explore
this dissin universe but then
mathematically it's it's
it could be very likely that we're in a
simulation but I definitely think more
that we're not this is wow this is
exciting
good for you Kido could be very likely
the vanilla the nuanced approach it's
yeah yeah yeah and then what do you
thinks the most beautiful thing in the
world
I like I like retinas I mean they're
very colorful and textured and they're
beautiful and if you spend time looking
at them I think give you a happier
healthier person Wow
it's the first time we've had that
answer on the show it's ready I like
that one I like that one
it is it's it's actually like proven to
be yeah 30 to 60 seconds of just looking
at each other in the eyes is like just
proven to be so much really
yeah grounding for humans yeah
emotionally embodying you like the whole
thing where you're behind a computer
keyboard like trolling or yelling at
other panels like that gets canceled out
when you look at the mouse for 30
seconds you're like wow this is another
human that is like has their own complex
life you know right yeah versus behind
this stuff is just yeah so that's a good
one like that one
you feel that oxytocin yum yum yum yum
yum you love love love yeah it's good
stuff see though this has been an
excellent episode I really appreciate do
we have another audience question um
yeah okay Eugene Otto Diggs
Tito's climate optimism I love it thanks
for you come I was working on a smart
mobile game to capture 1% of
what to find clean tech and organization
that can save the planet and advance
humanity that's what we're working great
so everybody I'm watching the show thank
you so much for watching and
participating we greatly appreciate and
be sure to send your contribution to
simulation series yeah every meal comm
PayPal yeah doo doo doo hook it up yeah
literally a cup of coffee that you spend
every single month can literally
dramatically change the direction of our
program and make it much much more
effective for us to implement what you
guys would like to see as a more optimal
show so let's do it together
Lotito thank you so much for coming on
that's right yeah we really appreciate
it
yet seeing things as an opportunity I
love it the one trillion tons of carbon
let's sequester that let's see it as an
opportunity everyone check out the links
in the bio below to the newsletter as
well as to by- calm impossible apps
aiello and air miners or talk to talk
about these things with your friends
your family coworkers people online on
social media get talking about this as
an opportunity get talking about sharing
and get building in the space where's
the website to buy the mug o for this
it's b y- dot-com by negative b y- comm
also sign up for the newsletter cuz the
batch 2 is gonna be coming of these soon
because they sold out batch one already
and the newsletter links to the bio as
well and support the artists
organizations and entrepreneurs around
the world that you believe and support
them in your local community support
simulation our links are below the five
billion dollar a person who just did it
yeah they get it even the 5 bucks a
month helps a lot everyone seriously
really really dive in there Ron Vargas
thank you very much for producing and
directing we greatly appreciate it and
go build the future everyone manifest
your dream since the world thank you so
much for tuning in we will see you soon
please
[Music]